Okay.
A lot of people loved it when to close out
2019 I played a game of chess against producer
Pat.
Check that out on YouTube.
We've got a video of it on our YouTube channel.
It turns out that there are many chess players
in our audience.
I've played against some of them during live
streams that I've done.
So today I am announcing we are having our
own chess tournament on Lee chess.org that's
the platform that we're going to be using.
This is open to anybody.
It doesn't matter how good you are, doesn't
matter how bad you are.
It's open to absolutely everybody who wants
to play the tournament will take place.
Not this Tuesday, next Tuesday, February 21st
at 8:00 PM Eastern time, assuming no crazy
things happen because of, you know, Trump
impeachment causing debates to be moved or
whatever the plan is.
Tuesday evening, February 21st 8:00 PM this
will be a one hour tournament.
Some tournaments go on for hours and hours
and hours.
We're a political talk show, so I think a
one hour chess tournament is appropriate.
We will be playing a format that is what's
called three plus two meaning each player
will start with three minutes.
Every move you make, you get an incremental
two additional seconds for each move that
you make.
I will be live streaming my participation
in it, so if you don't want to play, you can
just watch me participate in it.
I am certainly not going to win this tournament.
There is some really good chess players in
our audience and I expect, uh, I'm taking
the position that merely to compete is an
honor and that I have no expectations as to
how I will do.
Uh, so we will link to, we won't have the
link for the tournament until about half an
hour before it starts.
I will tweet it out.
We will have the link on our YouTube and Twitch
streams that will be going on.
So join the fun Tuesday, February 21st 8:00
PM Eastern time winner will get something
we were thinking of of of a nice custom made
trophy.
You can get trophies made, custom engraved.
It's not that expensive.
We can send it out to the winter.
That's one idea.
Uh, I dunno, I'm open to ideas for what the
winners should get, but I hope you will participate.
My goal, we've never done anything like this
before.
My goal is to have 50 participants.
I don't know if that's high or low.
I know that there are at least a couple dozen
chess players in our audience, whether they
will all be available at 8:00 PM on Tuesday,
the 21st to participate in this.
I don't know.
Um, but I hope you'll join us.
It's going to be great.
The winner will get something.
It'll go for an hour.
I would suggest that if you want to play plan
to get online about 15 minutes early@sevenfortyfiveandmakeanaccountonleechess.org
in advance.
That's ally chess.org totally free website
to, to play on.
I'm David Pakman on that website.
The reason I say get on 15 minutes before
is make sure that you have time to get the
link for the tournament.
Make sure you hit join tournament and then
it's just good to wait.
There'll be a countdown to the start of the
tournament.
That's my suggestion.
I will have more information about this upcoming,
but very exciting stuff.
50 players is my goal and hopefully we will,
uh, we will achieve that.
Okay.